à 26 ans j'ai fait un serment
de cette couche parle
on m'a demandé si ce que j'avais fait
valait le coup de prendre 25 piges
maintenant je vais voir si c'est le cas
Freddy je veux que tu partes à
sérieux là
[Musique]
tu peux te faire des couilles en or
faire tout ce qui te plaît je veux voir
tes livres de cons vous travaillez pour
le gouvernement j'ai mis ton vigile KO
et tu crois que je fais du
fiscalité parce que j'ai failli me faire
descendre
je savais pas que c'était un crime mais
mon uplobe
à la prendre
assumes là où tu es censé être
c'est tout bosses pour moi ça va nous
rapporter un pognontre
les clubs les discothèques ils
discothèque le jour le petit concert
bientôt
cette ville sera à moi
si quelqu'un te demande quel métier je
fais tu réponds que je suis un
industriel qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
bah c'est le but de la manœuvre